Pope Francis is praying for an end to
the pandemic during a special prayer
usually reserved for Christmas and
Easter
the Pope prayed in a deserted and rainy
st. Peter's Square Friday for an end to
what he called an unexpected turbulent
storm it comes as the outbreak appears
to have struck another cruise ship
leaving more than 1,000 passengers
stranded as they battle flu-like
symptoms Roxana Saberi is live with that
part of the story Roxana good morning
good morning Dana the zaandam cruise
ship has been trying to get to Florida
but it's now stuck off the coast of
Panama the cruise line says four
passengers have died while the number of
people feeling sick is rising fast
denied passage through the Panama Canal
the zaandam sits stranded at sea with at
least two people on board testing
positive for COBIT 19 and nearly 140
reporting flu-like symptoms passengers
like Chris Joyner and his wife Anna are
pleading for help to go home the world
nearly 28,000 people have now died from
the virus in Spain the death toll
climbed to nearly 5,000 the world's
second highest after Italy at
overwhelmed hospitals like this one near
Madrid patients lined the hallways still
some positive news officials say the
rate of new infections is slowing in
France where the virus has killed nearly
2,000 people the government has extended
a nationwide lockdown by two weeks here
to some hospitals are overrun they're
transferring patients to West crowded
regions by trying to thank health care
workers for their efforts the Eiffel
Tower lit up last night with the word
there see I've developed mild symptoms
of the Carina virus and in Britain Prime
Minister Boris Johnson became the first
world leader known to have tested
positive for the corona virus he self
isolating and he's been keeping a safe
distance from 93 year-old Queen
Elizabeth with their most recent
meetings by phone
a nationwide lockdown here in the UK
began last Monday but critics say
Johnson
acted too slowly against the virus the
countries confirmed cases have been
doubling about every three days and Jeff
we just learned that Spain has reported
more than 800 new deaths in the last 24
hours
Roxana thank you very much